hey Victor uh
before we get to the game I was just
wondering your reaction to pop uh
signing a five-year contract
his reaction
oh
um you know it's
of course it's it's just another sign
from from him and from the franchise
that
they care about the project there's
something something great going on
starting and uh yeah I just you know
we we kind of knew it was going to
happen but now it's you know let's get
it rolling
we can get started now
Victor
sorry I can't hear you was it a
byproduct of the flow of the game or had
you made up your mind that you wanted to
be more aggressive tonight you looked
especially after you got the first
basket after you after you got your
first one to go down it just seemed like
there was a lot more aggression from you
on the offensive end especially tonight
was that by Design or just sort of the
way the game happened
you know to me it's just um
it's just me me getting comfortable with
with myself with my body with the court
because uh
you know before today I had like uh two
practices in one game so
uh it's just I was just getting going
physicality of the game yeah how's your
face and and what is the difference have
you noticed so far obviously this is
Summer League it's not the real NBA
season but what have you noticed is the
difference between the league you were
playing in and the style of play here
you know it's first of all the court is
more open
uh is going fast but it's it's less
physical and uh
and I get found a lot but not as much
nothing to compare and uh yes and people
are
like
people are here people are players are
just flying you know out there is more
on the ground pushing underground big
box outs here it's
great athletes the best in the world
more way more Talent
and uh yeah but I like this better
though
hey Victor
um obviously it's just summer league but
after your debut how good did it feel to
have a performance like you just did
tonight
you know uh I wish we would have won the
game and uh
it's yeah I think I could have done more
to to have my team win this game it is
we gotta keep learning and uh
we've been uh We've we haven't been
playing our best for like three quarters
but in the fourth we were really
dominating and uh
it shows a real personality of a team
and uh
I think that
personally I'm just you know uh it's
normal to get to get better every game
two days ago was my first game I had
like a summer going on with the
draft with the media and stuff so
I gotta so it's just you know it makes
sense
Victor to kind of jump on Melissa's
question I know it's not your goal to
give these people a show but was there
just a small part of you that was a bit
relieved to give them the show that you
gave them tonight
no you know it's
this I think the best show for for the
fans is the is the win so uh obviously
it's just summer league but um
yeah I think I think they can see they
can see us developing they could they
could see us developing tonight getting
better and so yeah it's I think we
yeah we gave them a good show
yes uh you have two actually really good
agents one in particular uh Bona just
wanted to ask you what he's meant to you
over the years and uh
kind of impact does he have on you on a
daily basis
what's the first time I could ask this
you know when I was actually uh I've
known him for a long time he was he knew
my parents for a long time before and
um even though he's he's supposed to be
the best and he's a James he's agency is
supposed to be the best in France and
one of the best in the world
it wasn't a an obvious an obvious choice
for me to to work with them back I'm I'm
saying like three four years ago and uh
so but uh when I when I sat down and
talked to him and Jeremy also uh I saw
that
I felt like they could be more than just
agents you know and uh because there are
people who are trying to actually know
me and uh who don't care about they
don't care about the money they don't
care about the the contracts they're not
trying to make me sign the most
marketing contracts you know because we
got something greater to to entertain we
got some something greater going on and
uh yeah like they they strive for for
greatness and uh I think in the whole
world they'll probably the the only the
only people who would that suit me to to
be my agents
Victor to pick up on that Luna told me
tonight in fact that you told him I just
want to get back to playing basketball
are you glad now that with these all
this over that that that's what you can
concentrate on
yeah yeah it's you know in the past
month uh and I think basketball wasn't
even 50 of my schedule that was you know
I can't stand it I know it's it's a
special moment in my life but it's
I'm glad it's over honestly it's I just
want to Hope I just wanna work out lift
and because this is my life obviously
everyone I mean every first pick gotta
go through this
but uh yeah it just just make me makes
me better for the future
uh building on that what is what are the
rest of your plans for the summer do you
plan on playing anymore in summer league
and then after that what is what are the
next two three months gonna look like
for you heading into the season you know
uh I know I gotta I gotta talk with pop
uh I'm gonna listen to what he's gonna
say but I'm ready to I'm ready to make
any sacrifice for the team and uh give a
hundred percent
and um
yeah I'm just I'm just gonna I need to
sit down with this person to to know
what the the next months are going to be
like when to
when to go on vacation went to
start back working out where I'm gonna
practice in San Antonio somewhere else
and uh yeah I just know we got as I'm
not playing in the World Cup we got two
to three months two to three great
months ago that are coming and they're
gonna they're gonna change my life I'm
probably gonna disappear from the media
for for next month honestly
foreign
[Music]
um
why what is
foreign
[Music]
computer
is
[Music]
thanks